Tucker had a nice little take on the
ending of the world economic Forum they
brought in some entertainers at the end
and there was this incredible floutist
she was a floutist without a flout take
a look
time to check in with our lizard
overlords in Davos Switzerland what are
they up to well this
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you for watching
yeah those people run the world
they're so impressive
what a bunch of freaks
okay I want a hit on what Tucker said
there at the end those people run the
world question mark I think look it all
seems scary and they are plotting
against us I mean they really are and
they do send these Stooges like Justin
Trudeau and Gavin Newsom they send these
people into Western democracies but I'm
telling you guys I really really believe
this this this is not the best of the
best that we're up against these are
incompetent buffoons who idea whose
ideas are so anti-human that they cannot
win we just need to be a little bit
braver pushing back on it we just need
to expose them more and that's why they
want censorship of course but a lot of
the stuff that they have pushed over the
last couple years is being exposed in
real time and good people not crazy
right-wing Maniacs good decent people
who are apolitical who just want to go
about living their lives they're
figuring it out
foreign
[Music]